[Music]
good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime i'm jesse waters day two of
deliberations is wrapped as pressure
mounts for the jury to convict kyle
rittenhouse outside the courthouse fists
are flying gatorade is getting dumped on
people's heads and there's even been two
arrests the protesters are getting rowdy
demanding a guilty verdict from the jury
i'm here
to support the calls for kyle to go to
prison for a very long time he literally
crossed the state line with an assault
rifle
into a hostile environment you know you
don't go to a buffet with a fork and say
i'm not hungry we need to hope and pray
to whatever god arbitrate figure in the
sky you believe in whatever that kyle
rittenhouse goes to jail
these protesters and blm activists don't
care about the evidence and they don't
care about justice either they only care
about mob justice i've said this before
this is a clear-cut case of self-defense
so what's taking so long why haven't the
jurors reached a verdict the speculation
is they're afraid of the fallout they're
afraid that if the angry mob doesn't get
its way there's going to be a price to
pay
and that's exactly what these
bloodthirsty prosecutors want and they
are bloodthirsty today we learned that
they hid evidence from the defense
we were provided a copy
of that from mr krauss that was neither
in the length
or
definition clarity that the state had
we
did not get
the full
download that they received until
saturday of sunday of last weekend
after all the evidence was closed
and
that's a real problem the prosecution
has had no problem playing dirty for
this trial and neither's got the media
they've managed to twist this entire
case and even the judges fed up with it
when i talked about
um
problems with the media when this trial
started
that's
we're there in part not not fully but in
part because of grossly irresponsible
handling of
what comes out of this trial i will tell
you this
i'm going to think long and hard about
live television a trial again next time
it's been a fake news media circus with
a kid at the center of it but this trial
is just one example of what democrats
are willing to do to take down their
political opponents
look what we learned about the fbi
threat tagging parents who criticize
radical school boards
and then last week the fbi raided the
home of a conservative journalist james
o'keefe
imagine if trump raided jim acosta's
house would cnn be okay with that
obviously not
but they're okay with all of this
because that's the mission they're on
always on offense
the left doesn't care if an innocent
individual's freedom is at stake they're
on a mission to destroy you and the
foundation of this great nation anyone
who gets in their path is dust
but it shouldn't be that way this time
tonight all eyes are on this jury
and whether they'll hold the line